目前在团队就刚才那个分享开始也提到过就是我目前是在团队是短视频扣端的负责人但是我们团队的那个职责目前也不仅是视频就是总之就是负义的流相关的业务我们都会都都会做对然后并且
比如说还有直播这些也都是我们团队在弄现在然后实际执行的就是一个是肯定是跟团队里的兄弟们一起搬装的一员还有就是有的时候一些需求瞒不过来也补位一下大家这样的一个职责然后的话然后
元素這邊的話就是從一個新手開發者到目前的角色就是經歷了哪些成長階段這個如果說從寫帶網開始算開發那我應該開始開發了很長時間了大概十多年了吧十五六年因為我高中開始接觸這一塊就比較就一直都比較感興趣然後每一階段比如說
我感觉首先是那个中学的时候中学的时候那会儿整体还是兴趣驱动嘛然后当时学习了那个VBRVCR这些然后到了大学大学主要就是做了很非常非常多的那些密斯系统就是管理性系统啊比如说什么手术管理性系统啊就是写了非常非常多很恶心的带忙那些然后当时大学用的主要是ASP.net和
然后并且大学也初步接触了一些多媒体方面的内容但是这个是跟着实验室的师兄和老师做的一些项目到了研究生阶段呢主要是做C效果还有一些研究生和实习的阶段做C效果和一些教教的服务当开放比较多那最终后面我在学校离开学校的时候
就直接串业了然后串业的时候就开始进入了那个IOS开发的世界然后就一直做IOS开发做到现在就是这么几个阶段嗯ok然后的话呃如果需要连说这边给我们总结一下就是对你成长帮助最大的三个点就是你会觉得是你三个点三个点嗯对想一想首先第一个点就是我感觉新区是最好的老师
就是当时我为什么特别喜欢这件事情是可能我一开始学的时候并不是自己主动学的嘛然后当时没有人给我认为也没有就很多那种到学再开始接触的同学他可能接触编程的时候就已经是需要面临各种各样的作业和任务了很多同学就觉得说这种面向解提式的可能并不一定要觉得很好玩但我当时接触的时候我更多的关注的是
我可以用它做什么?就是像你有很多基础的工具啊什么的你可以用它来创造很多很有意思很好玩的东西所以我感觉成长的版主就到的就是我对这个事情有兴趣我感觉这第一个点第二个点版主最大的第二个点可能是进入UC宝我感觉就是这边的
缉分我还是比较浓厚的,并且我在这边也做了相对长的一段时间因为我相比我之前创业的时候,我之前创业的时候更够的是我带着一般人在解决各种各样的业务问题那我们解决问题的幅度或者说程度一般就是解决百分之七十因为你想解决百分之一百的问题之后,后百分之三十的OI并没有那么高而且对于一个创业公司而言它是很昂贵的
那这样也导致说我当时技术人物什么都懂然后但是深度方面有一些现决但进入UC之后我有了很多的机会然后去做后面版本30的事情也让我的技术有所提升对第三个点第三点暂时没想出来OK那我听下来感觉的话就是个人的兴趣和自己就是所处的这样一个平台
或者说是对平台的一个选择可能是对连输帮助比较大的点对吧嗯啊不过我现在想了一点还有一点就是嗯我有个看法就是嗯因为程序员很多时候我们都会有自己的side project就是自己业余实验搞的项目然后有的时候我们会在会嗯
但也是曾经有同学跟我这么聊过就是说他觉得工作没意思他现在所有经历或者说兴趣都在我的个人项目上面然后他也希望个人项目可以让他学到更多更多东西但是我自己感觉其实你不管你对个人项目有多么的关注
它最终可能你能投入的时间也就是校班回家的那么一到两个小时但是你在公司你可能要待一天所以说还有一个点是我们可能需要主动的去挖掘和寻找怎么样在公司的项目里面也能够成长也能够学到东西或者说对深入进去这样子的话其实善于说你必须把你的那个技术跟你从事的工作
产生一些连接 这样才比较容易有更好的效果对 这也是我们的一个感触OK 那么第三个点的话我听下来应该就是说善于从自己现在城市的这个工作或者是业务中挖掘出一些基地可以展开深入研究的一些点甚至说可以把它变成自己的签名或者是说在这里推动下去做一些
呃拍人库或者是拍像不管是这种架构一些就是方法还是说一些UI库其实都是有就是类似的就是方法去可以就就做类似的改造会推动对对的ok行好那接下来的话呃别人说这边就是可以给大家分享一下就是平时都是通过什么样的渠道来学习的呢或者说有哪些就是高校学习的方法之类的
因为我平时是可能是一个略微有一些懒或者说比较拖延的一个人所以说我当我真的效率决定想学一个东西的时候我请靠这个决心是不够的因为我很有可能别过几天我可能就懈怠了所以我一般都会把它搞成一个任务就是比方说flag先立出去或者说呃呆的那些设立起来然后跟相关的山下游那这样子
一个是核心就是保证自己的投入的效率那比如像分享这些事情也是我一般就是我报名分享都很积极但分享前夕都很崩溃就说我有感觉我知道好不想很不想去投入时间去弄这个事情然后说没时间什么的但是每次分享完成之后都感觉我自己在这个过程中其实也是学到一些东西的
所以第一个点就是通过带的辆让自己保持投入和产出的效率那第二个点呢就是我会从一些数据啊或者说呃就是跟算法有关的一些呃内容我比较喜欢去那个medium看就关于什么深度学习啊或者帮质的然后这一些呃资料medium的那个出品还是比较不错的就是比比较体系对
然后其他的就是买书尤其是相对难一点的东西我都倾向于买书去看因为看网上的文章有的时候感觉看标题似乎它都是能解决自己问题的营当但是很多文章它其实都策证点都相对单一你作为一个学习某一块东西的目的去看介绍那块东西的文章其实比较不容易学进去所以我更倾向一个是买书
所以这一次分享也是被迫的吗是的前期确实有点后悔因为感觉平时工作或者说业余导导游戏什么的都都还不错但是也得去准备一下分享所以就是有一个就是大家经常开玩笑说的叫滴滴滴就是电脑驱动开发对好那么对接下来的话就是
联书结合一下就自身经验就是你认为的技术专家成长路径应该是怎么样的对就比如说聊一聊就是怎么做技术站管理啊就之类的是记录专家首先我感觉就是你首先在发现一个你比较那个热爱的记录方向然后
或者说你能够爱上你现在所从事的技术工作就我还是之前的观点嘛就是你做一个事情你有兴趣就没兴趣它其实效果还是差别是很大的这第一个方面你有这个东西你才能够持续做下去那第二个呢就是说你在做这个事情的时候你得理解这个事情的全貌就不是说我们要扑广度我们要做全账啊而是说
我当一个做的一个事情我做这个我做这个技术的时候他的山上游是什么样子他这个东西背后的原理是什么这些东西可能要关注一下江云说你只有理解了一个事情的全貌之后你才能够有更正确的当点突破的方向那第三个点就是还是要通过你目前面临的问题然后做一些突破然后深入进去他说比较抽象
反正就是就用了 iOS 来说吧首先你第一步肯定是你要先成为你得对这玩意儿感兴趣对吧然后你写一些业务写得比较好这是第一步第二步就是你除了完全影响做的事情之外你开始关注一些性能方面的东西然后你通过解决一些性能问题你也发现这些性能问题的成因
然后再一次发言,然后在之后呢就你得需要知道说这个行业的RS的那些专家们他们都在解决什么样的问题那些问题是他们才遇到吗?还是说我自己也有可能遇到然后他们的解决方式是什么?这个就是理解这个技术领域的全报到最后才是说那我现在工作是做这个
那这个IOS的这些东西我都已经知道了那我如果工作最应该去突破这些哪个点了然后再突破哪个点对于我这个这个工作的业务更有帮助呢然后再选择一个点去突破大概就这样一个事物嗯OK就是说除了可能就是从自己的工作或者说自己平时遇到的一些技术问题就这些方向上面去进行突破以外还可以去参考一下业界其他一些
呃开发人员或者是说一些其他光丝遇到的一些问题就是不是说呃自己这边也有同样的对然后大概听下来可能就是对这一块上面就是可以有就是突破的点对好那么前面这些问题的话主要是跟联书就是聊了一些联书关于一个人成长还有自己的做发展这一块的一些问题那接下来呃后半部分问题可能就主要是
一些团队相关的问题吧就是联书这边的话因为目前还是在UC是负责短视频客户端这一块对吧就是你可以大概就是跟我们聊一下UC团队的文化是什么样子呢就是说可以是公司文化也可以是团队的技术文化其实技术团队的文化呢UC这边基本上和和那个其他的一些
互联网道产差别都不到就我经历了两轮文化嘛就是当年当年UZ干贝奥利斯购的时候呢还保留一部分UZ的文化就比如什么大五啊或者就是大家对同学相撑啊这些然后呃呃最近逐渐就是都对齐到奥利的嘛但是本质都其实都没有改变就是还是提倡平等然后鼓励创新
大概就是这样的一种文化其实我感觉就类似比如像字节还有字节范吧但是字节范提的那些东西在我们公司也能找到对应的说法就是文化企业基本都差不多有一种就是成功的公司或者是成功的团队都是相似的吧就感觉就是如果是或者是失败的公司就失败的人就是各不相同
对然后如果是比较成功的公司或者团队可能他们都会有一些比较相似的点或者是说都有就是同样的优点或者怎么样对然后但是感觉呢其实这只是一个方面因为其实文化对于一个公司的重要性我个人是存疑的就是除了文化之外其实定多的还是说一个一个成功的公司他
有一些固有的基因然后这些基因能够让他很擅长的去做一些事情而且比如说像那个UC的话他在做一些工具和体验下面的能力是比较强的我认为一直以来包含UC的内核啊以及现在flutter的内核这些okok行好 接下来就是可能就是直播间的双向比较关心的一个问题就是联书的
团队目前还有HC吗就是然后我们就是如果说就是招聘的话联说这边是怎么看就是比较看重候选人的那那一块的素质或者是能力对嗯好呃团队的HC目前是有的只是说呃招聘暂时还没有恢复就是因为他是有
就公司他有一些阶段就目前是可能是盘点阶段比较多所以说还没有放开还是要过一段时间那比较看重的素质呢就我们这边面是比较看重的就是呃一个就是那个应聘者的一些基础就是计算机的基础比如说他对于呃测到系统啊或者是计算机网络的一些常识性的问题有没有自己的呃有没有sense就会通过一些其他问题
比如说另外就是一个是这些方面另外就是对于数据结构跟算法但不会面很难算法题甚至说算法题也不太会但是会问一些看他有没有数据结构sense的东西就比如说他有没有在解决一些问题的时候有没有利用比如空间换时间这样一些思路来解决问题
那除了这个呢更多的就是会看他过往的项目经验一个是看他在过往做项目的时候是否有做的那种呃有追求极致就比如说他的做事方法是比如说做的差不多就摆在一边还是说他会呃不断的呃挖一些神的东西比如不断把体验做的特别好或者说不断把这个发作的特别全面特别体系来看他做事的一个方法乱
这是一个方面 第二个方面就是看他对于刚才提到的就说比如IS它的一些几道重要的方向有没有一些经验或者说认识比如说稳定性或者说假设比如他是做那种视频相关的那他对于音视频的一些普遍的认识大概是处于一个什么样的程度
对其实就是从总结一下吧总结一下就是一个是计算机的基础第二个就是过往的项目经验然后当过往的项目经验不纯粹只是说看他是不是真的这些项目是他做的而是说通过这些项目来看他自己的一个工作方法和工作方式以及对于某一块领域的经验是否符合我们的要求主要是这么级连
那比如说刚才是从这个招聘的角度来看就是候选人那如果是联书这边就是接下来要考虑下一家公司或者是下一个团队的时候那么就是你会有哪些自己关注的点或者是说比如说如果有朋友来找你问这个问题你大概会怎么样就是给他一些建议
我主要会分两个层面去考虑吧,首先就是行业就是首先要问自己为什么要进入这个行业,比如说这个行业它算是朝阳产业的,还是西洋产业,还是说是一个疲惫的产业对吧那第二个呢就是说,就比如说现在大家都觉得文车是一个文教是一个很好的方向那这种我们就认为它是不是算持续的有增量的产业,就比如说
假设你交由公司,只要这个公司没死,他都可以随着这个产业的发展而发展这种就是躺着就基本做不要做错事就能够有得不错的发展但你要去一种比如已经非常卷的公司比如现在的移动互联网就大家的做新用户都会拿那你就代表说你去了你不能躺了,你得保平你得卷出来你才能有发展那这种就
不太一样,首先要想清楚这一点那第二点呢就说区内药公司所从事的基础方向和你自己的兴趣是否契合如果说你是那种能够干一行爱一行的人呢那估计就不是很不是很重要这个问题但如果说说你是那种有兴趣才会做得比较好没兴趣就比较底出了那肯定还是要了解清楚一些内药公司都是做什么的主要是这两个方向吧
那就是总结下来的话一个就是那行业就是说或者是说行业的就是大方向上的发展对第二个的话可能就是说除了行业之外的话可能就是说公司一个具体的就是个人从谁一个技术方向有没有一个比较就是好的一个状态了就就不至于说自己选择的时候就选一些就是本来就是比较卷的这样一个技术方向对
ok 那么就是连输这边的话包括前面也说了嘛就是连输大概也有非常长时间的这样一个不管是工作也好还是说coding上面来说也好都有一个非常长的一个长夜的时间那么在连输的职业生涯中就是有没有困惑过呢或者是说遇到一些比较迷茫的
呃时间段然后当时是怎么样处理的就是怎么样自己就是度过这些迷茫的时间怎么样去最终找到一个比较好的解决方案对所以跟大家分享一下嗯呃迷茫的时间我相信呃应该不少iOS开发同学或许都遇到过就是比如我之前在那个串业结束的时候有想过我到底还要不要做iOS看起来好像做后台更好
就感觉iOS跳板是不是很明显什么的但是有这么困惑过但是后面也没有付出行动就是感觉一个是自己过去iOS上积累确实还是比较多二个是我当时做虽然说在串业阶段也做过后端但确实理解是比较浅的对一套所以我后面还是选择了iOS工作那该选择的时候肯定也是困惑的不过当时就我心疯一个点就是说
当你不知道该干什么的时候你又先考虑把你的工作干好就不考虑你会不会吃亏什么的那些东西你就是把你工作干得很好就干到说你换一个别人来肯定干得要么顶多跟你一样就不然或者说顶多跟你一样不可能超过你或者不如或者不如你之类就当密码的时候就就这么做完然后做了一段时间就发现说只要
理论上这个行业只要说他还有他的用户基础还是可以保证的那他就有演员就会有非常多有挑战值得挑战的问题让你去成长所以说本账来说那个迷茫是怎么过呢还是说认真工作然后做了做了就感觉又不能够迷茫了然后觉得说
即便做iOS也是可以有很多东西可以搞的而且也是有很多技能可以去点亮与成长的对对对对OK 成长来感觉就是说就是可能就是别人说这行或者是说这一个方向行不行可能是别人来看法但是它具体真的行不行或者说自己是不是合或者甚至说
有沒有辦法就是說有一個常駐的發展其實可能要自己先嘗試一下把當前手上的活做到最好然後再去做下一步的這樣一個判斷或者是決定因為別人的看法也不一定對嘛雖然也不一定錯但確實也不一定對那怎麼更好的判斷呢?
是有一个判断的那我觉得就肯定是坚定一些也不用看别人怎么看如果自己没有一个判断呢那我建议是可以看一下别人的看法的原因是什么他为什么会有这样的认识比如说有的人觉得iOS不好会不会是因为说他掌工做事的挫折比较多他又觉得不好还是说他他对iOS全非常了解他所有公司都干过然后干完之后发现这个确实不好
这样两种人他的判断的教职对你来说的参考可参考意义是不一样的嘛所以说当然自己也没有判断真的很迷茫的时候不凡去一一了解一下那些给你建议的人他建议的逻辑和推导是推导过程是怎么样的这样子的话也更容易形成自己的一个判断而这样的判断也会让自己更有信心我觉得其实
好像很多人对lx开发的看法主要主要单用的点是因为lx开发其实就是靠Apple在撑着嘛而且最主要的点就是有一个前车事件就是那个诺基亚当时的那个栽培系统一眼之间就就没了的这样一个市场分的就没了嘛所以就是很多人会担心说A会不会说苹果哪一天
也像这样这样这样对业之间就就没了然后呢所有的开发者可能到时候也就只能说很很突然的去要去就是换新的方向或者怎么样我觉得可能大家比较担忧一点在这因为如果你说去做不管是其他不管是前端也好还是后端也好其实可能不会非常重的去依赖某一家公司对
但其实本质上来说当你做iOS你做的那个时间比较长了之后你会发现无论是swift的语言还是oc语言还是那个urk的这些sdk对于你来说都只是数而已那你做的时间长了你成长了之后你收获的那些道就比如说是
怎么做性能优化比如你怎么在有限的内存和时间里面让移动设备上的动画能够特别顺畅其实这些东西反倒是可以跟iOS的系统货许到很多所以这些东西其实都是可以迁移到你未来的一个新的平台的迁移不过去了可能只有一些特有的那些语法而已但那些东西其实并不会花你多少时间
有些平台的坑,对了,因为其实接口设计都是比较相似的,就换一个一种套路情况。对,就你在iOS,你在做iOS工程师解决一些各种各样业务问题的时候,你记得的那些方法论其实是不会随着iOS被淘汰而淘汰的。所以虽然说iOS确实不一定是可以一直长清下去的,但是
他也对于你而言对其中的业内从业者而言他的风险也并没有那么大不会说一夜归零那种感觉感谢联署对然后的话接下来这样一个问题也是我们今天最后一个问题了对就是对移动开发这样一个行业未来的发展的展望以及个人有什么规划其实我们上一个问题刚才也稍微聊到一下这个顶对就联署可以稍微再展开一下讲一下这个问题
首先就是第一个判断就是我感觉移动开发还没有过时就虽然现在大家都在喊一些很Fancy的东西就比如说比如长R啊或者说等等吧然后但是为什么我移动开发整个过时呢就是你还是可以从用户的就是使用使用习惯来看就比如说我们每个人对于手机的依赖
其实是只多不少的只是我们在手机上干的事情越来越多了那从这样一个角度你的用户都一直都在只是说你需要比以前更努力的从中挖去才能找到你自己的位置所以说下一说移动开发还没过时只是更捲了这个判断是我们现在的一个看法那第二个就是
个人的一个规划呢就是我自己还是从两个视角来看第一个是生存的视角就是首先我我自己肯定也面临所谓的35岁危机就中年危机码程序员的所以说要怎么样对赌那个处理这个危机呢一方面就是肯定你首先你你还是能让活你还是得保持你的技术敏锐度还有就是技术能力
但另外一个方面呢就人们就会觉得说那假设你做的事情和年轻人一样那肯定年轻人有更好的那个体力劳力能够并且对于那个待遇能够有一个更低的更高的容忍度对于那个不好的待遇那你跟年轻人的经验力是什么那从这样的问题我想的就是说我想的解决方法就是说我们
还是应该有所谓的CEO视角什么意思呢就是我们现在在做的业务我们不能局限于说我是这个业务某个环节的一个研发而是说我要站在说假设我觉得这个业务的老板那我应该做些什么事情我应该做些什么事情能够解决目前业务的一些问题那通过这样的一种思考方法来补一下自己的短板换句话来说就是比如说我假设
这个业务现在是管理问题,那我就补一下人员管理的问题,那这个业务是项目管理的问题,那我是不是可以补一下项目管理的问题那通过这样的方式来加深自己对业务的理解那加深了之后,它目的就是不断的提升你自己这个人所能产生的教职那即便未来我到处去找工作,假设我既能跟一个年轻人一样做需求那我又能够能够把
目前的这几个研发大家给怎么样更好的带着他们一起做一些事情来提升目前他们目前研发团队的一些效能说白了就说我们需要思考说你怎么样向老板证明未来你的新公司的老板证明你这个人能够给公司创造新的教室那方法就是说
你在现在你就应该用CEO的视角去面对你在公司处理的业务让我说清楚了没那但这个是求生存的角度啊说白了就是那至于我自己的追求我其实是希望这辈子啥都不干去找寿不缺钱的话能够一直写写戴帽搞一些很酷的东西然后就就这么一辈子就一直搞一些研究一些辛劳的技术做一些很酷的事情
所以就说两条线应该是相辅相成嘛就是求生存的方面我们会通过一些思考的方法让自己对于各种各样的IT或者获利网项目能够有更高的利用价值这是生存方面那个人兴趣方面就是也会持续的去关注一些新的技术然后做一些研究然后争取就是
能够做一些一道两件很酷的事情这辈子对这个大概就是我自己对我未来人生的规划听起来有一种就是类似硅骨钢显霞的感觉还没说这是长的远对好的然后的话对今天的预议访谈的问题应该就到这里了对然后的话啊时间也差不多就用生了对然后非常感谢联书
这边给我们